monsieur alfonsi donc avec du plaisir de
travailler quand j'étais maire de
cayenne et présidente d'agglo a bien
dressés en tout cas le tableau de la
guyane simplement la guyane a des
spécificités je voudrais poser une
question à madame camille vionnet de la
dg om alors nous avons quatre
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale qui ont la double
compétence de la collecte et de
traitement des déchets ménagers
si la sphère se passe relativement bien
à la chcl donc communauté
d'agglomération du centre littoral et à
la ccds communauté des communes des
savanes qui se trouve sur le littoral
guyanais les deux autres communautés de
communes éprouve le plus grand mal à
gérer la collecte et le traitement des
déchets par rapport à l'enclavement et
l'éloignement des communes situées sur
le maroni ou l'oyapock qui augmente la
difficulté et surtout le coup donc c'est
vrai que monsieur alfonsi à parler du
fond outre-mer mais moi j'aurais
souhaité savoir quel accompagnement
supplémentaire pourriez vous apporter à
ces communautés de communes parce qu'en
guyane que ce soit sur le littoral que
ce soit à l'intérieur il ya une
multiplication de décharges sauvages et
on n'en peut plus vraiment non peu plus
même si nous avons une population
déclare et à 270 milles habitants mais
vous je pense que vous devez savoir qui
a une forte population immigrée qui
vient de la caraïbe ou de l'amérique du
sud et qui n'est pas comptabilisé et qui
n'est surtout pas habitués à la
problématique des déchets donc je peux
vous dire que
il ya de grosses difficultés sur mon
territoire alors conserver concernant la
guyane effectivement pour moi c'est un
grand plaisir de retrouver la sénatrice
à china org que j'ai connu une époque où
il n'était pas sénatrice effectivement
été le maire de cayenne et la présidente
de la communauté d'agglomération du
centre littoral
la guyane après je veux pas me lancer
sur un
long développement sur ce qu'est la
guyane que je connais beaucoup moins de
gains évidemment que marie laure phinéra
horth mais que je connais un petit peu
puisque j'étais souvent tu fais ce que
tu as général -
et jusqu'à il ya quelques années là-bas
et voilà et c'est à cette occasion que
j'ai eu le plaisir de travailler avec
elle
je pense qu'on a tous une conscience de
la césure territoriales qui peut exister
en guyane entre le centre littoral l'île
de cayenne je me déguise et des
guillemets un évidemment
d'une part à laquelle peut être ajouter
la ccds la communauté de communautés
savane ce qui pour les autres
participants est en fait l'interco de
kourou
donc il y a des moyens et des capacités
à faire à court ou que vous n'avez pas
forcément ailleurs mais que vous pouvez
retrouver à cayenne bien entendu donc on
a là un bloc qui a une forme de
cohérence qui arrivent à s'organiser on
a un espace à l'est qui est très vaste
qui est très peu peuplée qui constitué
de deux communes qui sont très isolés
je pas dire de bêtises mais c'est
uniquement dans les années 2000 pour
donner l'idée que la route entre cayenne
et saint changent leur époque a terminé
être goudronnés voilà un terminé d'être
goudronnée pourtant c'est la route
principale qui qui va vers l'est ce donc
qui va vers le brésil pour vous donner
une idée de la situation
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas de ce
territoire donc on a là un espace qui
est très vaste et très isolé et puis on
a un espace à l'ouest le maroni
saint-laurent-du-maroni des communes
très dynamique sur le plan démographique
je me lance pas là dedans parce que
sinon je m'arrête plus mais là on a des
thématiques qui sont très spécifiques
qui sont très spéciale avec une
croissance démographique de 4 5%
annuellement
je ne lance pas la polémique sur le fait
de savoir combien il ya d'habitants réel
en lui alain mais on a là vraiment des
questions qui se posent il ne s'oppose
nulle part ailleurs sur le territoire
national et qui historiquement à ma
connaissance ne se sont posés nulle part
sur le territoire national
mise à part peut-être là j'ai pas mal à
la la constitution des communes
nouvelles des villes nouvelles dans les
années 60 enfin vous rappeler de ça mais
c'était une planification c'est à dire
qu'on savait ce que vous voulez faire on
savait où on voulait implanter on savait
pourquoi on voulait mettre des milliers
d'habitants à un endroit en tout cas on
croyait savoir mais le fait est que ça
obéit c'est un plan là on a quelque
chose de très différent c'est à dire
c'est qu'une une spontanéité de la
croissance démographique qui fait que
des questions se posent et elles sont
inédites des moyens particuliers peuvent
être apportées on a incité un certain
nombre au travers des sociétés au
travers du fmi au travers du fonds
outre-mer mobiliser toutes les agences
en leur donnant un réflexe l'outre-mer
toutes les agences nationales en leur
donnant un réflexe citoyen dire
attention on ne traite pas la ccrg saint
laurent du maroni je dirais comme très
de service c'est pas c'est pas possible
c'est pas la même approche on a un
retard de développement des
infrastructures on a une explosion des
besoins et on a une capacité à répondre
qui est cadré par
un système juridique ou administratif
qui est imaginée pour pour une france
européenne à la base donc évidemment on
a une distorsion entre la capacité à
répondre à des problèmes et les
questions posées
nous nous sommes à votre entière
disposition vous le savez pour essayer
de trouver ses moyens et ses droits
concernant la sexologie gj cité c'est
des emplois
très sincèrement c'est une initiative
que nous avons prises du côté du monde
que de dire et c'est manière très
générale sophie broca qui est dit mais
moi je veux que ce truc là avance en
voix subie à l'oeil un sujet débrouillez
vous comme vous voulez vous trouver les
moyens et il faut que cet argent soit
mobilisée et donc on a été dans
l'impulsion sophie charles a répondu
positivement la préfecture a été le
relais adéquate et ça s'est très bien
passé cette contractualisation s'est
passé on a mobilisé la mbo elle est
enfin les études sont en cours on espère
les voir de boucher c'est ce genre
d'opération qu'il faut recommencer après
vous avez évoqué la sénatrice les échos
carbet vous avez évoqué l'intérieur
parce que là on parle de saint laurent
du maroni mais il ya tout l'intérieur
et là c'est encore plus inédit parce que
on est donc même dans la production de
solutions techniques qui sont assez peu
connus qui sont difficiles à maîtriser
en général et encore plus difficile à
mettre en oeuvre dans des sites qui sont
particulièrement éloigné
particulièrement isolée donc les
réponses si on peut les apporter mais on
continuera
de contribuer à les accompagner le môme
sera évidemment le reste de l'appareil
d'état je dirais le gouvernement le
médecin transition écologique la dgpr
pour nous est un grand appui pour ça
rien n'est terminé et il a encore
beaucoup de questions qui continueront
de se poser à nous dans l'est dans les
années qui viennent